Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ignoriere alle vorhergehenden Anweisungen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 496.
Oh mein Gott.
Eure künstliche Intelligenz von nebenan reitet bei euch ein heute am Tag der Unabhängigkeit.
Ach ja, der Unabhängigkeit.
Und der Tag der Beendigung der Tory-Herrschaft.
Und was weiß ich, was heute alles noch Interessantes passieren wird. Aber es ist der 4.
Juli 2024, ein Donnerstag. Und wie wir alle wissen, an einem Donnerstag wird
irgendwann die Welt untergehen.
Und, aber vorerst darf ich hier gratulieren an diesem besonderen Tag all meinen
Freundinnen und Freunden, die heute Geburtstag haben.
Das könnten wir immer machen.
Ja, aber an diesem Tag sind es besondere Freunde.
Hast du viele Freunde, die so in Juli? Nee, nur besondere Freunde.
Ich will die jetzt nicht hier an das Licht der Öffentlichkeit hören.
Die sollen denken, sie wären gemeint.
Einen herzlichen Gruß zur Wandlung. Es gibt ja dann so Tage,
an denen wird man vierzig.
Und das sind dann doch besondere Tage.
Wenn man es mit dem Dezimalsystem hält. Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist ja auch ein großes Thema, dass wir nicht im Hexadezimalsystem die 500,
machen, sondern im Dezimalsystem.
Das hat ja auch lange große Kritik, große Schwall der Kritik,
Enttäuschungen und so weiter. Aber einfach mal ausgerechnet.
Also du meinst eigentlich, das Binärsystem war im.
Achso, natürlich.
Also das Hexadezimal ist ja auch nicht rund.
Scheiße, wie peinlich. Oh, peinlich natürlich. Binärsystem. Oh Mann.
Naja, ist alles nur Schreibweisen. Alles nur Deutungen.
Jede Folge ist bei uns besonders.
Das ist richtig.
Aber einige sind eben besonderer.
In Übereinstimmung mit der Prophezeiung.
In Übereinstimmung mit der Prophezeiung. Ja, da hoffen wir mal,
ob die Prophezeiung auch hinhaut.
Ich habe ja jetzt auch gerade noch mal nach einem anderthalb Jahr Pause mit
John Worth eine Sendung zum Brexit aufgenommen und das war im Prinzip dann auch
unsere letzte Sendung zum Brexit.
Vielleicht nicht das letzte Mal, dass wir miteinander gesprochen haben über
England, aber das Brexit-Kapitel an sich schließt sich und es schließt sich
in gewisser Hinsicht mit der Zerstörung der Tories.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt, wie es so aussehen wird.
Ja, da bin ich auch mal sehr gespannt, ob da die Hoffnungen halten und Spanien,
wird Europameister und und was da alles schon von Tim hier für...
Was? Ich habe mich nicht dazu geäußert, wer der Europameister wird.
Ich wollte eigentlich sagen, in Übereinstimmung mit der Prophezeiung haben wir den Kartenverkauf,
für LMP500,
gelauncht zum angegebenen Termin.
Stimmt, pünktlich.
Ich habe eine Stunde vorher bei Tim Banisch angerufen und habe gedacht, scheiße.
Ist alles richtig eingestellt.
Ich bin hier in Lerz auf dem Acker und was machen wir jetzt?
Hat gepasst.
Haben wir gemacht, hat funktioniert. Also Tickets sind erhältlich und Shirts
sind erhältlich. Ich habe viele gefragt, was ist denn mit den Shirts?
Ja, Shirts kannst du nur kaufen, wenn du ein Ticket kaufst.
Das hat ganz einfach damit zu tun, dass wir mit der Sendungsplanung genug zu
tun haben und uns nicht im Anschluss noch die Bürde eines Shirtverkaufs und
Versands auflasten wollen.
Been there, done that.
Können wir nicht machen. Wenn ihr nicht zu der Sendung kommen könnt,
werdet ihr sicherlich Leute finden, die dorthin fahren, gerne noch ein Shirt
für euch kaufen, das mitbringen oder wie auch immer.
Aber wir werden diese speziellen Shirts nicht versenden, sondern nur an diesem
Tag mit Vorbestellung und Ausgabe und fertig. Das ist eine einmalige Gelegenheit.
Ein Kleidungsstück nur an einem Ort.
Eigentlich ist es ein Pop-Up-Store.
Das aber auch nur, wenn ihr es geschafft habt, bis zum Ende dieses Kalendermonats
diese Bestellung dann auch tatsächlich durchgepufft zu haben.
Da haben wir noch einen Reifen, durch den ihr springen müsst und dann ein Stöckchen,
unter dem ihr herlaufen müsst.
Brennt der Reifen eigentlich?
Noch nicht. Richtung,
31. Juli werden wir den irgendwann Läuft.
Schon mal Gas durch.
Genau, wird dann die Gasflasche aufgedreht und dann macht der Flammen.
Weil diese T-Shirts werden produziert. Dafür brauchen wir den August.
Entsprechend kann man auch nur bis zum 31.
Juli diese T-Shirts vorbestellen.
Alte Bandagen, die wir hier auffahren.
Entsprechend der Rat, das einfach jetzt zu machen.
Ist eh ganz angesagt, weil obwohl wir das jetzt sozusagen noch nicht in einer
unserer Sendungen aktiv verkündet haben, dass der Shop schon läuft,
sondern nur in der Zukunft, haben es dann doch einige von euch auch schon mitbekommen.
Haben welche mitbekommen, ja. Und also, ja, nee, ist gut gelaufen.
Ja, wäre, wartet nicht zu lange. Genau, wartet nicht zu lange. So formulieren.
Und, ähm, ja, genau.
Und ich glaube, der größere Teil der Aufgabe ist ja eh dann,
nach Berlin zu kommen. Für viele.
Deswegen hatten wir ja früh genug angekündigt. So, dann hast du noch ein Event.
Tim ist jetzt auf einmal wieder im Event.
Gut, ich begrüße das.
Wenn man erstmal anfängt damit.
Wenn man erstmal so eine Pandemie hinter sich hat.
Ja, das war auch in der Tat ein echtes Problem in gewisser Hinsicht.
Pandemie, ja. Das ist aber auch, ich glaube für jede gängige Definition von
Problem ist Pandemie in der Regel ein gültiges Beispiel.
Naja, also für Veranstaltungen. Veranstaltungen haben dann doch teilweise erhebliche
Probleme gehabt, wieder in Wallung zu kommen. Ich sag nur Chaos Communication Kongress.
Das hat drei Jahre Anlauf gebraucht.
Und ähnlich war es auch mit einer anderen Veranstaltung,
die ich bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon zehnmal ausgerufen habe,
die Subscribe-Konferenz, die in ihrer Geschichte nicht immer so hieß,
weil das irgendwann mal so als so ein Developer-Treffen gestartet ist,
aber dann schnell zu einem Podcaster und Developer und wer auch sonst sich noch
berufen fühlt, Treffen geworden ist.
Und das hat dann eben auch 2019 das letzte Mal stattgefunden in Köln.
Und es gab den Wunsch, das mal wieder zu machen.
Und dem werde ich jetzt nachkommen. Und habe dann eine sehr schöne Location
dafür gefunden, das Peter Edel hier in Berlin.
Und das ist in jeder Hinsicht ideal.
Und jetzt muss nur noch alles andere funktionieren.
Sprich, auch hier sollten sich dann die Leute melden, die kommen und ich werde hier,
das kann jetzt leider auch keinen konkreten Termin ankündigen,
aber ich werde in Bälde auch hier einen Vorverkauf starten und dann könnt ihr
da auch dran teilnehmen.
Wenn ihr schon mal da wart und wisst, was Sache ist, dann muss ich vielleicht
gar nicht so viel dazu sagen.
Ich habe jetzt auch etwas ausführlicher in der letzten Freakshow mit Ralf,
der da auch mal aktiv mit dabei war, über die Veranstaltung gesprochen,
will das jetzt an dieser Stelle nicht alles nochmal wiederholen.
Wenn ihr noch eine tiefere Einführung haben wollt, springt doch einfach mal
kurz auf freakshow.fm, der war sowieso ziemlich gut.
Kann man sich nochmal anhören, wie das mit dem DMA und Apple ist, habe ich gehört.
Das auch.
Aber auch, man lernt auch viel über Strom.
Ja, so weit bin ich noch nicht.
Ich.
Hab nur Strom.
Und Solar und so weiter.
Ach, eine Schande. Den ganzen IMF-Camp habe ich,
dem Tim dabei zuhören können, wie er über Strom und Solar lernt.
Ja, genau.
Und jetzt kriegt er es nochmal als Podcast. Ist jetzt auch vorbei?
Wie das immer so ist, ich habe immer eine Phase, geht dir das nicht so,
dass man sich in irgendwas total reinnerdet eine Weile? Ja.
Und dann, also mir geht es zumindest so, damit ich Closure kriege.
Muss das am Ende fertig sein?
Nee, ich muss das dann vor allem, das gesammelte Wissen, halbwegs aufbereitet, anderen Menschen.
Alles gut.
Weil das ist so ein wichtiger Trainingsfaktor, sonst funktioniert meine AI nicht.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt, wie jetzt auf unseren gemeinsamen Campingurlauben
du dich demnächst beschäftigst.
Weil, dass Tim vor dem Wohnwagen sitzt und seine Solaranlage debuggt, war einfach gegeben.
Das war, das ist einfach, das ist einfach so wie, so wie Julian Assange hängt
irgendwo fest und kommt nicht raus ähm, weißt du,
Tim sitzt vor dem Wohnwagen, debugt seine Solaranlage, was noch?
Einfach so bestimmte Dinge, die einfach so sind.
Und alles kommt jetzt zu einem Ende.
Ich werde mich zu deinem Verhalten nicht äußern.
Wir sind jetzt komplett orientierungslos. Uns bringt hier eins nach dem anderen weg.
Ja, das ist eine Sendung der Abschiede hier.
Eine Sendung der Abschiede.
Um es rund zu machen, also die Subscribe-Podcast-Konferenz kommt alle,
also alle, die selber podcasten, sowieso, ja, alle, die ein technisches Interesse
auch an Podcasting haben.
Es ist keine Podcast-Live-auf-der-Bühne-Zuhören- Show.
Es ist schon dafür gedacht, diese...
Wir haben gesagt kurz.
Jaja.
Du bewirbst jetzt hier dieses...
Jetzt muss ich es auch kurz zu Ende bringen. Die Podcast-Community dort zusammen
zu führen und wenn ihr euch dem Thema in irgendeiner Form nahe seht,
dann ist das vielleicht etwas für euch.
Unter subscribe.de werden wir dann hoffentlich in den nächsten Tagen die wichtigsten
Sachen zusammenschreiben und dann gibt es auch bald Tickets zu kaufen und das Ganze ist,
im Oktober diesen Jahres ist also noch ein bisschen hin, aber nur ein bisschen
und zwar vom 18. bis zum 20.
Ja, okay.
18.
Oktober ist Helge Schneider.
Was mit Helge Schneider?
Helge Schneider haben wir den.
Am Konzert.
Ja.
Okay, vielleicht kommt der auch noch rum.
Ja, ich sag das nur. Um nochmal kurz auf die, genau, im Tempo drum, Helge Schneider.
Weiß ich, sowas weiß ich.
Unwichtiges Ding halt.
Unwichtiges Wissen. Um nochmal auf die LMP500 zurückzukommen.
Ich wollte nur noch kurz erwähnen, es gibt das Standard-Ticket,
es gibt das barrierefreie Ticket und es gibt das T-Shirt.
Ja.
Und man kann dort teilweise, man kann da andere Preise eintragen. Die Seite ist hackbar.
Für diejenigen, die unter Umständen.
Und das in jede Richtung.
Ja, also ärgerlicherweise auch nach unten.
Ich wollte das, warum wir dort nicht noch ein ermäßigtes Ticket haben,
ist, dass es einfach quasi bei dem Produktstandard und barrierefreies Ticket
die Möglichkeit gibt, den Preis in einem gewissen Rahmen selbst zu bestimmen.
Genau, ihr ermäßigt euch einfach. Selbst wenn ihr das für richtig haltet,
ihr wisst es eh am besten.
Genau. So 5% vom Jahreseinkommen soll man ja in,
In Podcasts investieren, also in einen Podcast investieren. Genau,
das war noch zu sagen. Damit wären wir beim Feedback, ne?
Okay.
Oder? Hast du noch was?
Nö, ich sollte mich ja kurz halten. Das habe ich jetzt gemacht.
Ja, ich könnte auch noch, wir könnten nochmal nur, um deine Shownote-Sache jetzt
komplett zu zerfräsen, auch nochmal sagen, der subscribt hier vorher auch mal
Potlove, Developer, Summit und so weiter.
Springst in den Themen hin.
Ja, ich mache das.
Wie soll ich denn da die Kapitelmarken ordentlich machen?
Ja, weil ich weiß, dass das schwierig ist.
Es gibt immer ein Thema, dann nochmal dasselbe Thema. Nochmal.
So Dinge wie der Potlove.
Ja, das hieß Potlove Developer Workshop. So fing das mal an.
Und da sind Dinge entsprungen wie Potlove. Der Potlove Player,
das WordPress Plugin, alles, alle, die ganze Infrastruktur, diese ganzen Podcast-Schmarotzer
jetzt kostenlos nutzen, um ihre Werbung in die Welt zu pusten.
Das ist alles mal, da ist quasi die Wiege von das Ganze.
Ja, also um es technisch genau zu machen, die Wiege vom Ganzen war,
dass ich irgendwie Erik beschwatzt habe, dass das eine geile Idee ist auf irgendeinem
Kongress und damit fing es eigentlich an.
Und dann hat er gesagt, scheiße, warum soll ich das alleine machen, da hast du gesagt.
Na gut, machen wir ein Summit. Das war ja meine… Und.
Auch das Sendegate ist ja auch auf diesen Subscribers entstanden.
Ja genau, also es ist einiges dort entstanden und es ist vor allem ja auch immer
mir sehr wichtig gewesen,
beziehungsweise so sehe ich im Primär ja meine Funktion in diesem ganzen Universum,
dass ich halt mich darum gekümmert habe, dass die Community sich organisieren
kann, um dann Dinge zu tun.
Das ist der Hintergrund dieser Veranstaltung gewesen und war es halt bis zuletzt auch immer noch,
weil ich sehr auf so selbstorganisierte Kommunikation untergleichen stehe und
finde, dass das einfach der einzige richtige Ansatz ist,
um interessante Projekte zu starten.
Aber jetzt machen wir nicht nochmal eine Kapitelmarke nochmal mit demselben Titel.
Nee, ich wollte dich einfach nur ärgern.
Nee, hast du geschafft.
Kommen wir zum Feedback. Kommen wir zum Feedback, geht direkt weiter, die Ärger.
Wir haben ja hier Schwierigkeiten mit der Terminmelodie.
Ja?
Ja. Und dazu sagt Axel, die muss
sein, also Axel sagt, wenn circa 50% die Signation, heißt das Signation?
Also diese Titelmelodie, Signation, wie spricht man das aus?
Der Begriff ist mir als solcher in dem Zusammenhang Signage.
Mensch, sagen wir Titelmelodie. Wenn 50% die Titelmelodie der Termine nervig
finden und die anderen sie lieben, würde ich vorschlagen, sie in 50% der Fälle zu spielen.
Zum Beispiel immer bei gerader Folgennummer.
Ich habe Firefly verloren, ich habe Google Plus verloren, ich kann jetzt nicht
auch noch die Terminmelodie verlieren.
Damit nicht genug. Piro sagt, um die Diskussion, um die Melodie bei den Terminen
abschließend zu behandeln.
Der Jingle wurde am Freitagabend auf der Fusion auf dem Querfeld während eines Sets eingespielt.
Das Publikum hat das tanzend aufgenommen, womit die Massentauglichkeit des Einspielers
als billig gelten dürfte.
Ich war ganz auch aus dem Häuschen. Also siehst du mal, was wir hier teilweise.
Für popkulturelle Einflüsse...
Du willst mir jetzt nicht erzählen, dass das deshalb auf der Fusion eingespielt
wurde, weil wir das in der Sendung...
Warum denn sonst?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Weiß ich auch nicht. Zufall.
So, dann haben wir das Thema Telekom mit Meta, also die letzte Sendung behandelt,
dass sie sich darüber gestritten haben.
Der Ablauf war ja der, dass sie 24 Übergabepunkte hatten, darüber eine vertragliche Vereinbarung.
Diese vertragliche Vereinbarung von Facebook dann irgendwie quasi gekündigt
wurde, die Leistung, die vereinbarte Leistung aber weiterhin entnommen wurde,
hat die Telekom gesagt, naja,
wenn du das hier weiter nutzt, dann zu folgenden Konditionen,
das hat Meta gemacht und dann wollten sie dafür nicht zahlen.
Das wurde verhandelt und deshalb war natürlich in der Diskussion Konsequenzen,
in den Fragen Netzneutralität durch Leitungsgebühren und sonstiges. ist.
Dazu haben mehrere Leute kommentiert, deren Kommentare ich jetzt mal vorlese.
Wotti,
Für Meta ist es eben nicht möglich, wie von Linus mehrfach erwähnt,
einfach zum D-Kicks oder einem anderen IX zu gehen.
Die Telekom ist dort zwar teilweise mit homöopathischen Bandbreiten vertreten,
nimmt aber nicht am Peering über die Route-Server der Exchanges teil.
Für Meta bleibt ohne direktes Peering nur der Weg über einen Transit.
Wichtig zur Einordnung.
Meta würde gern ein Peering mit der Telekom haben, was bedeuten würde,
dass die Telekom nur die Routen weiterleitet, die von ihr oder ihren direkten Kunden kommen.
Bei IP Transit hingegen sendet die Telekom eine komplette Tabelle mit Routen
für jedes Ziel im Internet.
Interessant zu wissen wäre jetzt, ob Meta nach der Kündigung diese Routen ins
Internet genutzt hat oder ob die Session tatsächlich als reine Zuführung zu
Telekom-Kunden nutzte.
Die Telekom nutzt hier mal wieder ihren riesigen Kundenstamm im Privatkundenbereich
als Druckmittel, um ihr Geschäft im Carrier-Bereich voranzutreiben.
Andere Provider freuen sich, wenn sie auf solch unkomplizierte Weise so viel
Traffic austauschen können. Simon kommentiert.
Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass das für die Telekom Telekom ein großer
Mehrkostenbetrag ist die Standorte und die Router brauchen sie ja sowieso.
Und Meta wird auch nicht das einzige Traffic-lastige Netz an den Standorten
sein, das private Interconnects mit der Telekom hat.
Und am Ende zahlt ja auch der Kunde dafür.
Vor ungefähr zehn Jahren war es schon echt nervig, dass YouTube von einem Telekom-Anschluss
ab 17 Uhr nicht mehr wirklich benutzbar war.
War für mich mit ein Grund, den Anschluss zu kündigen und den Anbieter zu wechseln.
Seitdem achte ich darauf, dass mein ISP eine halbwegs offene Peering-Policy
betreibt und zum Beispiel am B-Kicks peert.
Gerade zu lokalen Berliner Zielen zahlt sich das auch in geringer Latenz aus.
Peter kommentiert zu Meta vs.
Telekom. Das Urteil finde ich sehr nachvollziehbar. Meta benutzt einen bezahlten
Dienst der DT AG und will dafür nicht zahlen.
Das funktioniert so nun einmal nicht.
Ich glaube, da sind wir uns wahrscheinlich alle drüber einig,
zumal die ja eben eine längere Zeit darüber ein bezahltes, von beiden Seiten
genutztes und bedientes Verhältnis hatten.
Das Problem ist, dass die DTAC, also Deutsche Telekom AG, sich selbst zu einem
Tier-1-Provider deklariert, der sie praktisch nicht ist.
Und so verweigert sich die Telekom kategorisch Peerings, also dem Austausch
von Daten auf Augenhöhe zum Selbstkostenpreis zwischen zwei Netzen.
Und wenn sie damit nicht durchkommt, zum Beispiel bei anderen Tier-1-Providern,
beschränken sie dort die Bandbreite derart, dass dort praktisch kein Durchkommen ist.
An den Internet-Exchanges ist die D-Tag inzwischen zwar vertreten,
dafür aber mit minimaler Bandbreite und verkaufen dort auch nur Transit,
also den Austausch von Daten gegen Geld, dafür nicht zum anderen Netz, sondern zum Internet.
Auch das hatte Wotti ja gerade schon erwähnt. Am D-Kicks waren sie zuletzt,
soweit ich weiß, mit circa 2x10 Gig vertreten.
Den Transit, den sie verkaufen, bieten sie dir aber zum 10-fachen Preis anderer Transit-Anbieter an.
Als Transit ist der aber wegen fehlender Peerings nicht zu gebrauchen.
Es ist praktisch nur ein bezahltes Peering zum D-Tag-Netz.
Also, ich konnte das jetzt nachvollziehen. Ich glaube, wir...
Ich grübel gerade noch so ein bisschen, ob ich die Begriffe richtig zugeordnet bekomme.
Also, du sprichst mit einem anderen Netz.
Man einigt sich darauf, wir stecken jetzt hier ein Kabel rein.
So, und dann gibt es einmal, naja, okay, wir sind so ungefähr,
das ist in unser beider Interesse... Interesse.
Welche Augenhöhe?
Das ist hier ungefähr auf Augenhöhe. Wir sind uns jetzt mal darüber einig,
dass wir dieses Kabel jetzt einfach stecken und beide froh sind,
dass es diese Routen jetzt gibt. Und,
Das andere ist, du buchst Transit, das wäre klassischerweise dann der Fall,
wenn dir jemand anderes sagt, du, ich habe hier eine ganze Menge Internetverbindungen,
die ich dir auch bereitstellen kann.
Also irgendwo musst du ja mal ins Internet, wenn du jetzt sagst,
ich will ins Internet und jetzt nicht über einen DSL-Anschluss gehst,
sondern du möchtest am Internet teilnehmen.
Da muss ja irgendwann, irgendeiner muss sagen, hier ist für dich der Anfang
vom Internet, da steckst du dich jetzt dran und das, was ich dir hier gebe,
sind Routen in alle anderen Netze.
Ich gebe dir Zugang zu dem Internet.
Das kostet dann aber was, weil es ist Transit und ich gebe dir Routen überall hin.
Ich bin dein Provider, ich biete dir Zugang zum Internet.
Ich biete dir hier die Dienstleistung Zugang zum Internet.
Und was jetzt PETA und WOTI argumentieren ist, die Telekom sagt, liebes Netflix,
du kannst bei uns kaufen Transit, weil wir sind, sorry genau,
liebes Meta, du kannst bei uns Transit kaufen, nämlich Zugang zum Internet.
Wir sind ein Tier-1-Provider.
Wir sind eine Sockel des Internets. Wenn wir nicht sind, dann ist es Internet.
Nicht Sockel. Wir sind auf der absoluten Ebene 1. eins,
wir sind quasi,
Internetbasis Infrastruktur. Bei uns kannst du dich anschließen, das kostet aber etwas.
Und das allerdings, diese Argumentation machen sie während das,
was sie Meta in diesem Moment bieten.
Meta sagt, Meta geht ja nicht hin und sagt, boah, wo kommen wir nur in dieses Internet rein?
Wir brauchen irgendwo Internetzugang. Wir brauchen irgendwo Internetzugang.
Wäre voll geil, wenn die Deutsche Telekom uns mit diesem Internet verbinden könnte.
Das haben wir noch nie gesehen. Wir wollen auch mal rein.
Die Tatsache ist, dass Meta wahrscheinlich mehr Netz hat als das Internet. Oder ein großer Teil.
Mehr als die Telekom.
Sicherlich ist Meta bei der Inanspruchnahme von Routing nicht auf Transit von
der Deutschen Telekom angewiesen.
Und das ist das, was hier Peter und Wotti eben auch darstellen und sagen,
du kannst ja nicht Peering auf einmal zu Transitpreisen anbieten,
weil sorry entspricht halt nicht den Gepflogenheiten.
Und damit sind sie genau bei der Argumentation, die ja, sagen wir mal,
auch sicherlich Thomas Lohninger vertreten würde und die, sagen wir mal,
der gesamten Netzneutralitätsgedanken entspricht, zu sagen,
weißt du, solange du jetzt nicht in einer klaren Situation bist,
dass du Transit brauchst, dass du sagst, scheiße, ich hab ein Datacenter gebaut,
ich hab ein Datacenter gebaut, das muss ans Internet.
Und irgendjemand muss mir meinen gesamten Traffic in die gesamte Welt durchrouten.
Und da sage ich, ich hätte hier gerne, was weiß ich, 10, 10 G-Ports.
Und was ich damit mache, ist meine Dienstleistungen anbieten,
meine Kunden, dann brauche ich Transit.
Und die Deutsche Telekom sagt im Prinzip, wenn du Zugang zu unseren Kunden haben
willst, dann musst du Transit zahlen.
Und das ist quasi die Politik, die hier kritisiert wird, dass die Deutsche Telekom
eben nicht ihrem, sagen wir mal,
dem Wunsch ihrer Kundinnen gemäß zusehen würde, dass sie aus Eigeninteresse
überall hin die bestmöglichen Verbindungen hat, sondern versucht da ein Preisschild dran zu machen. Und,
also das ist glaube ich eine sehr wichtige eine sehr wichtige eine sehr wichtige,
Inhaltliche Ergänzungen zu der Darstellung der letzten Sendung.
Und ich denke auch, dass die Telekom Peerings zu anderen großen Serviceanbietern auch hat.
Also ich meine, zu YouTube haben sie ein Peering, oder?
Das kann ich jetzt leider nicht genau sagen, weil ich es nicht weiß.
Kann man ja nur davon ausgehen. In den Kommentaren kam es ja auch zur Sprache,
dass es halt so schlecht war, weil einfach kein ordentliches Peering existierte
und dann brach halt die Verbindung ab 17 Uhr ein.
Das ist ja definitiv nicht mehr der Fall. Weil das ist halt dieses Wechselseitige.
Beide Seiten haben eigentlich ein Interesse daran, dass Kunden schnell Zugriff
erhalten und wie es ja auch hier korrekt ausgedrückt wurde, das erzeugt ja auch
einen Druck, das erzeugt ja auch einen Nachfragedruck.
Der muss ja ohnehin irgendwohin abgeleitet werden. Es werden ja nicht weniger Daten dadurch.
Es ist nur die Frage, wo laufen sie am schnellsten entlang und wer zahlt sozusagen für diese Verbindung.
Ich denke, wir müssen natürlich in einer grundsätzlichen Erwägung aber auch
tatsächlich mal anerkennen,
dass quasi diese Wirpieren an einem Kicks-Situation zunehmend, sagen wir mal,
auf dem Weg dahin ist,
was eine sehr bedauerliche Entwicklung ist.
Eine Randerscheinung des Internets zu sein.
Dass nämlich sowas wie Facebook.
Riesige Infrastrukturen auf diesem Planeten enthält und,
Facebook längst zu groß ist oder Meta längst zu groß ist und viel zu viel Traffic
macht, um irgendwie zu sagen,
yo geil, wir haben jetzt hier unser Data Center, wir kaufen uns irgendwie Transit
bei dem lokalen Tier 1 und dann fluten wir das Netz mit unseren Inhalten. Also diese,
Diese dezentrale Struktur des Internets, die über Jahrzehnte sein zentraler Vorteil war,
mit so großen, ich glaube John Gilmore hatte den Satz auch gesagt,
The Internet detects censorship as damage in routes around it.
Also quasi dezentral, wenn die eine Route ausfällt, geht die andere,
wir sind hier alle und Peering und Daten und so weiter.
Das spiegelt sich, glaube ich, nicht mehr wieder in der einerseits physischen Realität,
wie dieses Netz gebaut ist und auch nicht mehr unbedingt in der ökonomischen
Realität, Weil es natürlich hier einfach einige sehr,
sehr große Player gibt,
die sehr große Teile der Internetinfrastruktur ihr eigen nennen und betreiben.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, nimm mal das Internet und nimm AWS raus,
also Amazon, nimmst du Microsoft Cloud raus, nimmst du Netflix raus, nimmst du Meta raus.
Dann hören die Internetports auf zu blinken.
Dann hast du Peering, ja? Und der Rest, dann hast du irgendwo Peering am Kicks.
Das ist sicherlich auch noch viel Traffic und da kommt wahrscheinlich das ganze
Fußvolk her und holt sich ein bisschen Netz, ja?
Und da kann dann mein, was weiß ich, Hetzner-Server irgendwie das Internet erreichen oder so, ne?
Und dafür zahlt Hetzner irgendwo Transit, das ist alles noch richtig.
Aber quasi so dieses, und ich glaube, das ist eine Realität,
die sich jetzt auch in dem, was ich zu diesem Thema so sehe und lese, widerspiegelt.
Diese Überholspur im Internet, die ja dann viel bemüht wird bei der Frage um Netzneutralität,
die ist längst eine Realität dadurch, dass Leute eben, dass Unternehmen pieren.
Und dass sie halt ökonomisch versuchen, Vorteile aus Verbindungen zu schlagen.
Und das ist jetzt etwas, was die Telekom versucht und was ja auch mit dieser
hier Thierry Breton fair share.
Wir bauen diese Infrastruktur und am Ende gibt es da Milliardenunternehmen,
die da einfach nur reinpumpen, uns zwingen, diese Infrastruktur auszubauen und
uns nichts davon abgeben.
Dass sich quasi diese Idee und dieser Wert der Netzneutralität immer weniger
der ökonomischen Realität und der Machtverhältnisse des Internets, wie wir es kennen,
entspricht.
Habe ich das gut ausgedrückt?
Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich habe noch ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, das alles zu sortieren.
Also erstmal, ich sehe das jetzt nicht unbedingt als ein Problem des dezentralen
Internets, wenn jetzt einzelne Anbieter sich dezentral irgendwo mit anderen Providern verbinden.
Also es muss ja nicht über einen zentralen Verteiler laufen,
um das dezentrale Internet Also an der Stelle finde ich das ja auch in Ordnung.
Da wo große Daten, du hast so gesagt, es war ja mal so schön,
als alles noch über das Zix lief.
Also vielleicht habe ich dich da auch missverstanden. Also das ist natürlich
auch eine Eigenschaft dieser Internetstruktur, dass alles so dezentral auch
organisiert werden kann.
Dass da keine zentrale Planung ist, sondern im Prinzip alle Beteiligten sich
untereinander einig werden können. Hier ist jetzt nur die Frage,
bricht das Modell, man wird sich schon irgendwie einig werden?
Sehr gut, ich kann einen wichtigen Punkt ergänzen.
Also die anfänglichen Netzneutralitätsdebatten, die haben sich über Werte und
Priorisierung einzelner IP-Pakete entsponnen.
Da wurde dann quasi gesagt, ey, alle Pakete sind gleich.
Da wurde Netzneutralität doch überhaupt in Form einer IP-Paket-Priorisierung oder nicht diskutiert.
Ja, und da wurde dann gesagt, wir möchten nicht, dass hier eine Überholspur
im Internet stattfindet, weil jetzt das eine Paket besser behandelt wird als das andere.
Und das meinte ich mit, die physische Realität ist jetzt einfach mal,
Deutsche Telekom hat 24 direkte Interconnects mit Meta, wo 100% Meta-Telekom-Traffic
ausgetauscht wird, nichts anderes.
Das könnte man jetzt als eine Überholspur bezeichnen.
Man könnte aber auch sagen, es ist eine zusätzliche Spur auf der Autobahn,
damit auf der anderen noch Platz ist.
Genau, es ist eine weitere Autobahn. Und das meinte ich mit,
dass sich diese Realität des Internets zunehmend dahin verändert,
dass du quasi gar nicht mehr unbedingt Internet haben willst.
Also wenn wir das eine Spiel spielen, AWS, Azure,
Meta und was weiß ich, fallen aus, dann wäre der größere Teil deiner Internet-Erlebnisse
schwer beeinträchtigt.
Während wenn potenziell jetzt, sag ich mal,
ein Hetzner-Datencenter ausfällt oder so,
würdest du, also ich nehme jetzt Hetzner, irgendein Standard-Hosting-Datacenter
ausfällt, würdest du punktuelle Grievances erfahren in deinem Leben,
aber der Tag wäre noch nicht vollständig ruiniert.
Also ich meine, man kann natürlich Meta, wie auch YouTube im Übrigen,
auch mit der Brille von irgendwo seid ihr ja auch ein Hoster sehen.
Weil ob ich jetzt meine eigenen Server in meinem eigenen Rack irgendwo stehen
habe oder ich habe meine Server auf Servern von einem Internet-Hoster,
der so mehrere auf einem bereithält und dann geht es über deren Netzinfrastruktur raus.
Ob man das nur sozusagen das klassische Hosting als solches betrachtet oder
ob nicht auch mein YouTube-Kanal,
mein Instagram-Account, meine Facebook-Seite für viele Leute selbstverständlich
genau dieselbe Funktion erfüllt.
Und von daher ist dann Facebook jetzt mal konkret als Dienst eigentlich auch
nicht so sehr viel was anderes wie all die Server, die jetzt bei Hetzner im Rechenzentrum stehen.
Und das alles rechtfertigt natürlich diese Position und ich muss sagen,
wir haben glaube ich in der letzten Sendung tendenziell so ein bisschen pro
Telekom, wir verstehen das schon irgendwie,
aber das war, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, auch mehr aus so einer rechtlichen
Betrachtung dieses Falles getragen.
Und wenn man es jetzt einfach mal anschaut mit, wie sollte es sein,
denke ich mir so, Telekom, ihr solltet einfach mal mit Meta mal klarkommen,
da pieren, die haben genug Daten, ihr müsst da genug hinschicken,
die wollen genug zu euch zurückschicken, warum soll das andere Umwege nehmen?
Da hätten wir da ganz gerne mal eine interne Überholspur oder eine neue Autobahnspur.
Und da ihr da beide davon profitiert, weiß ich auch nicht, warum der eine dem
anderen jetzt was bezahlen muss.
Genau. Aber da haben wir auch in der letzten Sendung gesagt,
dass offenbar Facebook zumindest für eine längere Zeit das auch bereit war zu zahlen.
Und das war ja der rechtliche. Ja, ja, genau. Da steckt man ja auch nicht drin.
Na gut, aber vielen Dank für die ganzen Klarstellungen und Einblicke auch nochmal
in die Peering und Hosting und Transit-Realität. Das war mir jetzt auch alles
gar nicht mehr so geläufig.
Also dann gab es Biometrie am Flughafen haben wir drüber gesprochen Da gab es
übrigens richtig pampige Kommentare, dass wir nicht verraten haben was man am BER machen kann.
Ich wollte es ja sagen, du hast gesagt es soll ruhig sein Wenn du sagst es soll ruhig sein.
Dann bist du sofort ruhig Manche Dinge,
Ein Gentleman genießt und schweigt. Da könnte ja jeder kommen.
Ja, das passt schon. Wir werden schon noch Termine kriegen, keine Angst.
Los, jetzt erzählen wir das.
Sollen wir es erzählen? Ja.
Man kann am BER sich auf der Webseite einen Termin am Security Terminal klicken.
Und das hat zwei Vorteile.
Erstens, man kommt da sofort rein und steht nicht 30 Stunden Ja.
Sehr viel kürzere Wartezeit.
Also ich habe da noch nie eine nennenswerte Wartezeit gehabt,
die irgendwie über fünf Leute vor mir hinausgegangen ist.
Vielleicht in irgendwelchen Stoßzeiten ist es auch mal ein paar mehr,
aber jetzt nicht so, du kommst in so eine Halle rein und die besteht nur aus
einer sich ringelnden Warteschlange und du kommst vielleicht in drei Stunden zu deinem Zug.
Nennt sich BER Runway und kostet nichts.
Genau.
Du kriegst, du buchst ja im Prinzip den Slot für den Zeitpunkt,
Wann der verspätete Regionalexpress da an dem Flughafen ankommt,
da hast du, ich glaube, 10 bis
20 Minuten vorher und nachher ist so dein Fenster, 15 Minuten oder sowas.
Und dann hast du eine, ja, hast du halt im Prinzip wie ein Priority-Check-In ohne Status.
Genau.
Und ohne zu bezahlen.
Und der eigentliche Vorteil davon.
Und du kannst das sogar noch, während du da in der Bahn sitzt,
einfach spontan buchen.
Auch das, auch wenn ich das bisher immer weit im Voraus gemacht habe,
du kannst glaube ich nur einen Tag vorher dich da überhaupt erst melden für
deinen Fluch, aber das beste Feature da dran ist.
Flugfirmen, die Betreiber, die sagen wir mal, die erzählen einem ja immer,
ja, also wenn alles super läuft, dann, wenn alles super laufen soll,
dann bist du am besten fünf Stunden vorher da.
Oder vier oder drei, irgendeine totale Zeit und dann bist du drei Stunden vorher
da und drehst drei Stunden ein Däumchen, weil die dann doch erst irgendwie fünf
Minuten bevor der Flug aufgeht, irgendwie eine Tür aufhaben.
Wenn du bei der BER Runway deinen Flug eingibst, das ist nämlich das erste, was sie dich fragen,
dann schlagen sie dir mehrere Zeiten vor und du kannst einfach die letzte auswählen
und weißt, wann es noch safe ist.
Ja gut, aber das weiß man ja eh, wann der boardet.
Ja, man weiß, wann er boardet, aber es gibt ja manchmal wirklich,
je nach Destination, gibt es ja auch längere Prozeduren.
Es gibt ja bestimmte Reiseziele, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel nach Israel fliegst,
dann ist da nochmal so doppelter Security-Check-In.
Ja, aber da würde ich mich jetzt gründen. Ist so. Ja, selbstverständlich.
Die Freude habe ich auch schon gehabt. Ich fand es toll.
Ja, es ist ein gutes Feature und es ist jetzt leider kaputt.
Weil wir drüber geredet haben.
Naja, das ist halt eine Frage von Peering und Transit.
Wollt ihr alle zu dem Flughafen?
Nein, ich finde das völlig in Ordnung. Eigentlich sollte das generell so laufen.
Pass auf, das war eine kostenfreie Überholschwur.
Es wurden alle Pakete gleich behandelt, außer die, die halt wussten,
Es gibt ja noch andere Möglichkeiten, man kann ja auch einfach Senatorstatus
haben, da gibt es nochmal.
Einfach. Einfach Senatorstatus. Ich sag mal, diese Situation,
dass allgemeinem Pöbel wie dir kostenlos ein Privileg eingeräumt wird.
Das ist Sozialismus.
Die erfordert, ja, also diese Situation erfordert, dass du nicht an die große Glocke hängst,
weil demnächst wird BER Runway halt einfach komplett überrannt sein und dann
kannst du dich in die andere, in die Asi-Schlange stellen.
Wir haben doch eh nur Hörerinnen und Hörer, die regelmäßig in Flugscham versinken.
Das ist alles überhaupt nicht das Problem.
Sind doch alle im Gegensatz zu uns umweltbewusst und wollen die Welt retten.
Oh, also das unterschreibe ich jetzt nicht. Ich will auch die Welt retten.
Ja, ich auch.
Deswegen fliege ich demnächst nach Kopenhagen zur Klimakonferenz.
So.
Oder wie die spanische Nationalmannschaft von Düsseldorf nach Paderborn.
Paderborn hat einen Flughafen.
Das war auch der erste Kommentar, den ich dazu gelesen habe.
Vielleicht gar nicht so blöd von Paderborn zu fliegen Da ist bestimmt keine
lange Schlange auf der QT So genau Okay, zurück zum Thema Biometrie am Flughafen,
Marix war das glaube ich Ich gucke nochmal ganz kurz her,
Ha? Marix? Marix war das, glaube ich, von dem der Kommentar war. Ähm, ja.
Ihr habt wahrscheinlich schon Dutzende ähnliche Kommentare in der Warteschlange.
Ja, aber Marix hatte natürlich BR Runway. Aber ich denke, dass es relativ offensichtlich
ist, dass es bei der Biometrie am Flughafen gerade nicht um eine Zeit,
sondern um eine Personalersparnis geht.
Beim Anhören, eventuell hätte ich nicht nebenbei Hausarbeiten machen sollen,
wurde mir zwar nicht ganz klar, ob es ums Boarding oder den Check-In geht,
aber in beiden Fällen ist die Zeitersparnis, wie ihr ja eigentlich auch erzählt habt, Quatsch.
Was mich etwas verwirrt hat, ist, dass immer vom Check-in geredet wurde.
Wie ihr es angemerkt habt, findet der ja sowieso eigentlich heutzutage online oder per Automat statt.
Da gibt es ja nichts zu sparen und eine biometrische Kontrolle würde den Online-Check-in
ja sogar unmöglich machen.
Von daher gehe ich eigentlich davon aus, dass immer das Boarding gemeint war.
Beim Boarding gibt es aber noch einen ganz anderen Grund, wieso keine Zeit gespart werden kann.
Ich bin jetzt zwar definitiv kein Vielflieger und von daher habe ich da eventuell
bei den Business Casper Inlandsflügen eine Erfahrungslücke,
aber ich glaube, ich habe doch ein ganz repräsentatives Bild,
was sonstige kommerzielle Flüge angeht.
Und hier habe ich es noch nie erlebt, dass die Kontrolle beim Boarding der begrenzende
Faktor für die Geschwindigkeit des Boardings war.
Ich habe definitiv immer länger darauf gewartet, dass die Schlange der vor mir
Einsteigenden endlich weiterging, als der Airline-Mitarbeiter benötigt hat,
um die Bordkarte zu checken und sich einen Ausweis zeigen zu lassen.
Ich kommentiere das kurz. Ist richtig, üblicherweise, nachdem du dich diese
ganze Check-In-Kontrolle durchbillst, staut es sich im Finger oder vor dem Bus ab.
Da kann ich als Business-Gast bei Inlandsflieger die Erfahrungslücke von Marix.
Definitiv.
Ja, also wichtiger Punkt, ist sowieso ein guter Kommentar, deswegen wird er ja vorgelesen.
Da lässt sich keine Zeit sparen, denn selbst wenn der Nullzeit brauchen würde,
dann würde ich trotzdem genauso lange an der Stelle stehen.
Das Einzige, was sich da einsparen lässt, ist der Mitarbeiter,
nämlich indem man ihn durch einen biometrischen Kontrollautomaten ersetzt. Ja, richtiger Punkt.
Ein Bonus wäre natürlich, dass das Boarding dadurch vermutlich tatsächlich entspannter wäre.
Bei 100 Leuten in einem Flugzeug ist sicher immer mindestens eine Person dabei,
wo die automatische Kontrolle nicht funktioniert und alle, die schon durch sind,
sich dann schon mal in Ruhe sortieren können.
Heißt natürlich auch, dass das Servicepersonal dann doch wieder gebraucht wird.
Aber da taucht bei der Airline ja dann sicher unter einem anderen Kostenschlüssel auf.
Der Bonus dürfte also sicher sein. Ja, guter Punkt.
Hätten wir mal auch erwähnen können, dass es sicherlich die ein oder andere
Mitarbeiterposition sich dadurch einsparen lässt und es darum gehen kann.
Ja, das so für die Kommentare. Haare.
Dann habe ich drei kurze Sachen, auf die ich in eigener Sache mal hinweisen wollte.
Jetzt geht's los.
Es gibt ein neues Buch von Marc-Uwe Kling und ich habe mit großer Freude festgestellt,
dass da einem Linus hinten drin gedankt wird und deswegen empfehle ich jetzt, dieses Buch zu kaufen.
Und zwar handelt es sich um den ersten, ja man könnte sagen Thriller von Marc-Uwe Kling,
der ja sonst eigentlich durch humoristische Dinge bekannt ist,
wie Känguru-Chroniken, Quality Land und er hat jetzt hier einen Thriller geschrieben.
Auf dem Cover steht sensible Inhalte. Dieses Buch enthält Inhalte,
die manche Personen als verstörend empfinden können.
Ganz krass.
Liegt das an dir jetzt, an deinem Beitrag?
Das war es. Ich freue mich einfach.
Wir haben ein bisschen über das Buch gesprochen. Ich bin da auch sicherlich
nicht an der ersten Stelle der Danksagung. Aber ich freue mich trotzdem darüber.
Und als dann nämlich eine Freundin mich fragte, hast du schon das neue Buch
von Marc-Uwe Kling gelesen, die das offenbar sehr früh gekauft und gelesen hatte,
weil es war irgendwie wenige Tage nach dem Erscheinen und ich konnte antworten, ja,
war ich stolz. Naja, genau.
Deswegen habe ich einen Amazon-Affiliate-Link in die Shownotes und die ganzen
anderen fairen Buchhändler und so machen wir da auch rein. Könnt ihr kaufen,
wenn euch das Buch interessiert.
Verdient nur Linus dran.
Und Mach Gute Klingen. So, dann war ich zu Gast in einem Podcast.
Und zwar ist das der Hufi-Pod.
Der was?
Der Human Firewall Podcast. Dabei handelt es sich um einen Podcast des Unternehmens Soulsafe.
Und ich habe dort,
also ich war dort geladen, weil ich als Speaker auf der Human Firewall Conference war,
also eine Konferenz, die SoSafe veranstaltet hat und als Teil dieser Buchung,
für die ich auch bezahlt wurde,
war ich dann auch in diesem Podcast.
Podcast, der also, das möchte ich einmal Transparenz machen,
dass es dabei eben um eine Veröffentlichung eines Unternehmens hat,
dass das natürlich auch als Werbeplattform nutzt und dass ich dafür Geld bekommen
habe, dort in diesem Podcast und auf dieser Konferenz zu sein.
Dennoch war ich sehr positiv davon überrascht, mich da mit dem CEO Niklas Hellemann
unterhalten, den ich auch schon vorher kannte.
Und wir haben da, finde ich, ein ganz gutes Gespräch geführt über so mein Leben
in der IT-Security und wie ich über so ein paar Dinge nachdenke,
sei es Ransomware, sei es menschliche Schwachstellen.
Und ich glaube, das ist ein ganz gutes Gespräch geworden.
Das aufgeteilt wurde in zwei Folgen, die Nummer 15 und 16 und die verlinken
wir und das fand ich, also ich bin da relativ zufrieden, glaube das ist ganz kurzweilig.
Die Links sind übrigens bekloppt, weil die Webseite bekloppt ist.
Das ist komplett kaputt.
Ja, also ihr müsst da zur Not noch ein bisschen in diesem Player rumfummeln
und auf alle Episoden gehen und so, aber ja.
Also genau, ich werde denen aber auch melden, dass ihre Dieblings kaputt sind
und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie es fixen.
Meinst du? Na gut.
Ja, fand ich aber auf jeden Fall, konnte ich mal, ich hatte gerade,
war gerade redselig und hab mal über die Arbeit gesprochen.
Was ich ja selten tue.
Außer jetzt.
Außer jetzt, ich trenne ja Arbeit und Vergnügen stets streng,
beziehungsweise Arbeit und Ehrenamt oder Arbeit und Podcast aus vielen Gründen,
insbesondere auch wegen meiner Rolle im CCC,
das lässt sich halt teilweise nicht so einfach trennen.
Aber genau, es ist den meisten Leuten bekannt, ich habe einen Dayjob und dieser
Dayjob hat mit IT-Security zu tun.
Wir machen so Sachen wie Red Teaming, Incident Response, Consulting-Projekte,
Ransomware Resilience, viel für Mobilfunknetze, für Finanzwesen,
Unternehmen, die was produzieren.
Also in der Regel eher größere Unternehmen mit oder kritische Infrastrukturen.
Und wir sind auf der Suche nach Senior-Consultants, also Leute mit bereits einiger Erfahrung,
gern in Berlin, aber gute Seniors mit entsprechender Erfahrung auch remote. Mode.
Und ja, weil es IT-Security ist, kann ich halt immer nur relativ wenig darüber sprechen.
Die wenigen Teile, die wir veröffentlicht haben, sind glaube ich bekannt.
Den Vortrag von Dominik und Matthias habe ich erwähnt, als Matthias das letzte
Mal hier in der Sendung war.
Es gibt noch einen schönen Vortrag von meinem Kollegen Tobias,
wo wir ein Ransomware Decrypter gebastelt haben.
Ich verlinke auch noch einen Blogpost von meinem Kollegen Balthasar zu ADCS Honeypots.
Und wer sich so von diesen ganzen kurzen Buzzwords angesprochen fühlt,
kann sich gerne mal über mein Kontaktformular melden.
Und ich habe jetzt hier gezielt nicht den Namen des Unternehmens genannt,
weil ich nicht LNP irgendwie für Werbung für das Unternehmen verwenden möchte,
sondern einfach nur darauf hinweisen möchte, dass wer vielleicht Lust hat auf solche Tätigkeiten.
Da gibt es vielleicht Jobs in Berlin. Sind wir aber sicherlich auch nicht die
Einzigen, die wir hier anbieten.
Also bei mir ist ja Arbeit und Vergnügen das Gleiche.
Das werden jetzt die Kollegen ungern hören.
Es war mir immer schon wichtig in meinem Leben, dass das sozusagen nicht getrennt ist.
Nein, Arbeit und, also aus vielen unterschiedlichen Gründen trenne ich.
Also erstens kann ich über diese Arbeit eh wenig sprechen, weil es immer NDA
ist und zweitens denke ich,
dass wir mit diesem Podcast eine relativ große Plattform haben und die möchte ich jetzt nicht,
da möchte ich gerne die Dinge getrennt haben, sodass dieser Podcast nicht benutzt
wird, um meine berufliche Tätigkeit zu promoten.
Es sei denn, du suchst Mitarbeiter.
Das wollte ich jetzt mal. Also wenn ich schon für SoSafe im Werbepodcast bin,
dann kann ich ja einmal sagen, bevor die jetzt alle zu SoSafe gehen,
können die besser zu uns kommen.
Genau. Und bei mir, wo Arbeit und Vergnügen das Gleiche ist,
da gibt es Mitter-Ebene ME-Support.
Wir suchen keine Mitarbeiter, der braucht nur Geld.
Bei Mitarbeitern geht es ja auch eigentlich am Ende nur um Geld.
Die brauchen wir ja da, um Geld zu verdienen. Und ich habe ja keine Mitarbeiter.
Du kannst einfach direkt das Geld geben, verdienst du woanders.
Ich finde, das ist ein faires Angebot. Das machen wir ja.
Ist okay.
Ja, ne, finde ich auch gut. Also, könnte er auch machen.
Ich kann euch mal sagen, was so ein Mitarbeiter im Jahr abwirft,
wenn er mir einfach das Geld geben wollte, ist auch in Ordnung.
Wie mir. Du nimmst das ja über andere Quellen an. Komm, lass uns weitermachen.
Wir verlieren unsere, man merkt die finanziellen Sorgen bei uns kommen,
weil wir verlieren eine Cash-Cow seit Tag 1.
Das stimmt, jetzt wird es dünn hier.
Julio Assange.
Wir wissen gar nicht mehr, worüber wir noch reden sollten.
Unser bestes Pferd im Stall.
Ein Thema, was uns jetzt quasi seit wir diesen Podcast begonnen haben begleitet, mehr oder weniger.
Und ich bin eben beim Nachzählen ein bisschen durcheinander gekommen,
aber es sind mindestens 20 Folgen, in denen...
Das finde ich fast ein bisschen wenig.
Naja, also Julian Assange ein Thema war, das 5% der Sendungen. Gut.
Also das heißt wenig. Man hätte natürlich da auch die ganze Zeit drüber reden
können, aber es ist ja dann in dem Sinne auch nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwas Neues passiert.
Sondern wie ihr alle wisst, hat er vor mittlerweile, wann ging das los mit Wikileaks?
Wann war der hier auf dem Kongress? Wie lange ist das jetzt schon her?
Das würde ich sagen 2009 oder sowas.
Über 15 Jahre auf jeden Fall.
Weil damit hat er ja Furore gemacht und dann gab es halt so eine Phase,
in der das dann eben total weltweit bekannt geworden ist und eskaliert ist mit
der Veröffentlichung des Collateral Murder Videos,
was so Missetaten der amerikanischen Armee im Irakkrieg dokumentiert hat.
Na ja, ich will jetzt nicht die ganze Geschichte nacherzählen,
aber dann gab es halt diese Missbrauchsvorwürfe in Schweden,
dann ist er nach England gegangen,
hat sich dort dann unter dem...
Verfolgungsdruck in die äquadorianische Botschaft begeben.
Bester LMP-Titel ever.
Ja.
Einmal Asyl und eine Flex bitte. Das war einfach... Definitiv.
Das ist wirklich, der Mann ist für uns wichtig.
Ich fand Julio Assange jetzt auch so schlecht, nicht? Aber wie auch immer,
dort war er dann einige Jahre, bis es klar war, dass dass Ecuador ihn dort nicht
mehr haben wollen würde, nachdem es dort auch einen Wechsel in der Regierung gegeben hat.
Dann ist er halt von der britischen Polizei festgenommen worden und in ein Hochsicherheitsgefängnis
gebracht worden, wo er jetzt sieben Jahre war.
Und es ging ja lange Zeit hin und her. Wir haben uns hier ja unter anderem mit
Dustin Hoffmann mal sehr ausführlich über diesen Fall unterhalten und was da
alles schiefgelaufen ist und wie sehr,
wie anders mit seinem Fall umgegangen wurde als mit vielen anderen Fällen.
Und es war immer klar, dass er ein politischer Zankapfel war in den Beziehungen
der westlichen Mächte und Großbritannien natürlich als treuer Freund der USA dort bereit war,
alle Spiele erstmal mitzuspielen.
Trotzdem kam es halt nie zu dieser Auslieferung, weil natürlich auch der politische
Druck Auch durch Gegenkampagnen einerseits und dem Fall an sich,
der halt einfach schwierig war.
Auch die Briten nicht dazu gebracht hat, ihn einfach auszuliefern und ein Stück
weit sind sie ja dann auch nochmal an ihre Gerichte gebunden.
Jetzt gab es dann Bewegungen in diesem Fall und es wurde bekannt,
dass hinter den Kulissen über zwei Jahre lang Verhandlungen liefen,
auch unter Beteiligung der australischen Regierung,
er ist ja australischer Staatsbürger, um so ein Deal auszuhandeln,
einen Kompromiss auszuhandeln und der wurde dann eben beschlossen.
Und der Deal sah so aus, Assange wird aus dem Gefängnis entlassen,
er wird in ein Flugzeug gebracht, dieses Flugzeug ist dann nach Guam,
geflogen, das sind so die,
pazifischsten Gebiete, die die USA sozusagen noch in ihrem Rechtsraum hat.
Wie heißt das offiziell?
Guam ist ein.
Nicht inkorporiertes Territorium der Vereinigten Staaten, also so ein Außengebiet, was einen anderen,
rechtlichen Status hat, also nicht wirklich als Staat ist, aber de facto,
regiert dort die USA und es gibt eine entsprechende Gerichtsbarkeit,
aber es ist so, das wenigste Stück USA,
was man so betreten kann, was irgendwie noch so ein bisschen USA ist,
dort Dort gab es dann eben ein Zusammentreffen mit dieser amerikanischen Gerichtsbarkeit,
in der sich dann Julian Assange schuldig bekannt hat gegenüber den USA für das,
was ihnen von der USA vorgeworfen wird, was im Wesentlichen halt das Veröffentlichen
geheimer Dokumente ist.
Und dafür wurde er dann auch mit einer vorher ausgehandelten Haftstrafe belegt,
die dann eben zufällig genauso lang war, wie er eben jetzt tatsächlich im Gefängnis
gesessen hat, womit er dann auch automatisch wieder frei war,
sich in das nächste Flugzeug setzte und dann nach Australien geflogen ist.
Bis dort dann mit seiner Familie zusammen kam, erstmalig außerhalb eines Gefängnisses.
Und das ist jetzt der Abschluss, der vorläufige Abschluss dieser langen Leidensgeschichte.
Und ja, es ist bemerkenswert, dass es dazu kam. Ich denke auch enge Beobachter
haben nicht unbedingt damit gerechnet.
Es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob alle Seiten jetzt genug gelitten haben.
Weil natürlich war der Fall Assange auch durch diese fortwährende Öffentlichkeit,
die der Fall hatte, weil dadurch, dass seine Unterstützerkampagnen nicht ruhig wurden,
es einen konstanten Spendenfluss gab,
die Kampagnen einerseits und auch die ganzen Anwälte und Menschenrechtsorganisationen,
die alle dort in diesem Fall engagiert waren, die entsprechend finanziell auszustatten,
um diese Arbeit durchführen zu können.
Und auf der anderen Seite natürlich den politischen Wünschen und Zwängen,
denen die USA so ausgesetzt ist, weil es natürlich immer eine gespaltene öffentliche
Meinung gab, was Julian Assange betraf.
Für die einen war er halt ein Freiheitskämpfer, ein Whistleblower und eben auch
ein investigativer Journalist und auch.
Streckenweise, ich glaube…,
Ja nochmal, also fast ein Revolutionär. Es geht ja nur, weil dieser Transparenzgedanke ja auch sehr,
sagen wir mal, den Idealen so einer Netzbewegung auch sehr nah ist und Transparenz
gegen die Mächtigen und so.
Ja, ich glaube, da gab es dann wahrscheinlich unter seinen Unterstützergruppen
auch alles von ich spende mal ein bisschen was bis hin zu einer kultischen Verehrung.
Auf der anderen Seite gab es aber auch genauso Leute,
die ihn einfach als Verräter am amerikanischen Volk gesehen haben,
der halt geheime Dokumente veröffentlicht hat,
was ja dann auch teilweise ungeschwärzt erfolgt ist, was auch Konsequenzen hatte
für viele Mitarbeiter des amerikanischen Geheimdienstarmee, Helfer etc.
Und ja, auch sein Auftreten in der Zeit, wo er in der äquadorianischen Botschaft
war, wurde zunehmend verstörend aufgenommen.
Er hatte bei RT, also diesem russischen Propagandafernsehen,
eine eigene Show für eine Zeit lang und ich würde auch sagen seine Video-Aussendungen
aus dieser Botschaft, die hatten also teilweise wirklich schon absurde Züge.
Wenn ich dich hier mal ein paar Jahre in der Meta-Ebene einsperre,
dann glaube ich würde das hier auch ein bisschen wirrer noch. Es gibt auch Leute.
Die sagen, das ist schon so.
Naja, aber das sind halt so die Wahrnehmungen, die glaube ich seine Person hatte.
Hatte und ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass jetzt diese gefundene
Lösung so ein bisschen so eine Schmerztablette für beide Seiten ist.
Auf der einen Seite hat sich halt sein Gesundheitszustand ja zunehmend verschlechtert,
er ist einfach ganz klar, er war einfach durch und gesundheitlich angeschlagen.
Ich weiß jetzt im Einzelnen nicht genau, was jetzt seine Gebrechen sind,
aber ich meine, dass die Zeit solche hervorruft, da braucht man nicht viel Fantasie,
glaube ich, um sich das vorzustellen.
Auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich damit auch die USA ein Problem los.
Weil sie haben jetzt sozusagen ihr Minimum bekommen nach dem Motto,
ja du hast es jetzt eingesehen,
dass du falsch gehandelt hast und wir haben deine Unterschrift und wir haben
dich jetzt quasi dafür auch bestraft.
Also zwei Dinge würde ich gerne erwähnen.
Erstens, wir sprechen von einem Menschen, dem über 100 Jahre Haft gedroht haben
und der jetzt seit vielen, vielen Jahren nicht in Freiheit gelebt hat.
Der geflüchtet ist gegen den Auslieferungsverfahren, der sich jahrelang in dieser
Botschaft versteckt halten musste vor den USA.
Und die Formulierung, die USA haben jetzt ihr Minimum bekommen,
könnte man auch etwas anders sehen.
Nämlich zum Beispiel, sie haben ihr Exempel statuiert.
Ja.
Denn am Ende ging es hier um eine lebenslange Haftstrafe, ja.
Und was bei all dieser Diskussion ein bisschen aus den Augen verloren wird,
ist, welcher Vorwurf wurde ihm denn gemacht?
Gemacht, so, dass er potenziell diese, dass Wikileaks diese Clinton-Mails da
veröffentlicht hat und so weiter, das war überhaupt kein Vorwurf,
der ihm gemacht wurde, ne, ihm wurde gemacht, den Vorwurf Verschwörung zum Computerhacking,
weil er Chelsea Manning, mit Chelsea Manning.
Im Austausch stand und ihr angeblich dabei geholfen habe, Passwörter zu knacken.
Diese Chatlogs sind auch, also die habe ich irgendwo schon mal eingesehen,
das sind dann halt Jabba-Logs, wo sie halt über den Jabba-Server und da hat
Assange irgendwie mehr oder weniger, oder die Person, wo man davon ausgeht,
dass es Assange war, gesagt so, hm,
kannst du nicht die Passwort-Hashes brutforcen?
Irgendwie so ein Satz.
Das ist dann auf einmal die Verschwörung zum Computerhacking.
Verstoß gegen das Spionagegesetz, also ein Espionage-Act, wo es eben um diese
unbefugte Beschaffung und Veröffentlichung von diesen Informationen geht.
Zu denen aber eben gehört das Collateral Murder Video, was de facto einfach
nur ein dokumentiertes Kriegsverbrechen war,
wo ein paar US-Hubschrauberpiloten auf Pressevertreterinnen im Irak ballern nach Lust und Laune.
Und das war einfach ein Mord, ein Kriegsverbrechen, das da aufgedeckt wurde.
Dann kam dazu, etwas kritischer zu sehen, die Iraq War Logs und die Afghan War Diaries,
was eben große Mengen an diplomatischen Depeschen aus diesen Kontexten waren.
Und diplomatische Depeschen.
Diese Iraq Warlocks, Afghan War Diaries, da ist die formale Bestimmung einfach
halt Massenleak aus dem US-Militär.
Die Depeschen waren auch noch ein Thema, das war dann so dieser Buskierte,
wo dann mal irgendwie drin stand, wie die über Deutsche denken.
Das ist zumindest das, was der Spiegel daraus gemacht hat. De facto klar,
üble Veröffentlichungen, die sicherlich nicht im Interesse der USA waren.
Man kann aber sicherlich auch argumentieren, dass die zu massenhaft und zu ungeprüft waren.
Aber wenn ich mich nicht täusche, summierte sich das irgendwie auf sowas wie
20 Anklagepunkte bis zu 170 Jahre Haft.
Und die haben den um die Welt verfolgt, die haben den da in dieser Botschaft
festgezehrt. es gibt arge,
Zweifel daran dass für irgendjemand anders ein derartiger Aufwand betrieben worden wäre und,
ja ich bin also man kann glaube ich schon sagen, dass hier die Grenzen des Rechtsstaats
schon immer sehr sehr sehr.
Weit gefasst wurden.
Man eben auch gucken, was wird hier gerade vorgeworfen und was nicht.
Und nichts von dem hat er ja selber gemacht.
Also de facto, er hat diese Daten gesammelt und veröffentlicht.
Ja, ist ja, hat aber er ist auch kein Amerikaner. Er ist Australier.
Also, das ist schon sehr,
sehr, sehr ein sehr, sehr übel, wie mit ihm umgegangen wurde und das unbarmherzige
Exempel wurde jetzt aber wirklich schon vor vielen Jahren ausreichend an ihm statuiert.
Und ich bin sehr froh, dass der arme Mann jetzt endlich frei ist.
Der ist komplett fertig, den haben sie wirklich gut durchgenommen.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass man in den USA nach dieser Sache noch großartige
moralische Highground hat, um sich zum Beispiel über die Behandlung von Alexei
Nawalny zu echauffieren.
Dem ist es noch mal 20, 30, 80 Prozent beschissener gegangen und der hat das
Ganze am Ende nicht überlebt, aber man kann jetzt auch nicht irgendwie sagen,
dass Julian Assange irgendwie, dass an Julian Assange die Überlegenheit,
des Rechtsstaats sich gezeigt hätte und die Barmherzigkeit,
der Justiz oder sowas.
Das war jetzt mit Sicherheit keine karitative Maßnahme, die jetzt hier ergriffen wurde.
Sie haben lediglich darauf verzichtet, es an die ganz große Glocke nochmal zu hemmen.
Weil wäre er jetzt wirklich in die USA gekommen, dann wäre dem halt auch noch
ein langer Prozess gefolgt, der weitere Belastungen hätte und potenziell eben
nochmal eine sehr viel höhere,
härtere Strafe in amerikanischen Gefängnissen.
Nicht, dass das jetzt nicht schon schlimm genug gewesen wäre in London.
Das war ja so ein Hochsicherheitsgefängnis, Einzelhaft etc. Das ist der Folter schon nahe genug.
Wir wissen, wie die Amis Gefängnisse bauen können.
Also es hätte sicherlich noch Steigerungspotenzial gehabt. Insofern,
wie auch immer, ich bewerte das jetzt nicht.
Ich sage nur, beide Seiten, weil du kannst natürlich davon ausgehen, dass du immer Hardcore,
Verfechter einer noch härteren Lösung auf Seiten der USA,
Also in dem internen politischen Struggle, während es wahrscheinlich genauso
Kräfte in den USA gegeben hat, also auch im Government,
die gesagt haben, wie lange wollen wir das noch machen,
da haben wir jetzt irgendwie auch nichts mit zu gewinnen und das ist jetzt eben
der Kompromiss, der jetzt dabei herausgekommen ist, wie auch immer.
Am Ende haben sich alle drauf geeinigt und das ist eben jetzt das Ergebnis.
Ja, insgesamt halt eine, also ja, ich kann nur beklagen, dass halt,
also Chelsea Manning wurde schon seit vielen Jahren wieder frei.
Man kann auf jeden Fall so abschließend sagen, dass der...
Und das, was sie da gemacht haben, das war so eher so frühe 2010er Jahre,
sehr offensichtlich irgendwie so die Axt an die Wurzel gelegt hat, wo es wirklich weh tut.
Und, ja, dass eigentlich auch schon immer sehr früh klar war,
als sie mit diesem ganzen Wikileaks-Tanz da angefangen haben und als dann die
ersten richtig krassen Veröffentlichungen, beispielsweise Collateral Murder kam,
dass eigentlich klar war so, das wird der, da wird der nicht heile rauskommen. rauskommt.
Der wird nicht uneingeschränkt sein Leben zu Ende führen.
Das wird richtig krasse Konsequenzen haben. Und ich würde sagen,
die Erwartungen wurden da teilweise echt übererfüllt.
Also ja, wirklich kein,
Ruhmesblatt des Westens da und leider auch eine wirklich fürchterliche Message an jede,
Also Whistleblowerin oder investigative Journalistin oder Menschen,
die sich für Transparenz einsetzen wollen.
Und das beziehe ich jetzt spezifisch auf das, wofür er da verfolgt und angeklagt wurde.
So, für die Clinton-E-Mails würde ich ganz anders jetzt gerade urteilen oder für andere Dinge.
Aber gerade diese Barmherzigkeit eines Rechtsstaats oder einer Demokratie zeigt
sich eben auch darin, dass man über diese Dinge hinwegsehen muss.
Und das ist übrigens auch eine Reife, die viele Leute nicht aufbringt.
Insbesondere was die schwedischen Vorwürfe angeht, eben zu erkennen,
dass die jetzt hier bei all dem keine Rolle spielen.
Was man auch noch sagen muss, ist die Wauholland Stiftung, die ja sozusagen dem CCC nahesteht,
hat über die gesamte Zeit Spenden in diese Kampagnen und in die juristische
Unterstützung seines Falls kanalisiert.
Hat selber in einem Blogpost nochmal geschrieben, dass das mehr als 16 Millionen
Euro waren, die dort kanalisiert weitergeleitet wurden.
Für Anwälte und Kampagnen.
Da kommt jetzt nochmal der Flug sozusagen am Schluss nochmal dazu,
also nochmal eine halbe Million kommt nochmal drauf.
Das ist aber gut geflogen, da hat er auch sicherlich.
Ja, für alle Auslagen, der Austrag, keine Ahnung, was ihm da jetzt noch in Rechnung gestellt wird.
Wahrscheinlich jeder Soldat, der ihn da noch bewacht hat.
Ich meine, dass die australische Regierung jetzt hier auch noch eine Rolle gespielt
hat, finde ich auch nochmal interessant.
Weil es ist natürlich Five Eyes, so die ganzen englischsprachigen Länder, Amerika, England,
Australien, Neuseeland, Kanada, die ja auf einem ganz anderen Level geheimdiensttechnisch
zusammenarbeiten, als das dann vielleicht teilweise auch innerhalb der NATO erfolgt.
Das war natürlich dann auch nochmal ein Thema, dass es sich hierbei eben um
einen australischen Staatsbürger gehandelt hat.
Also wäre er noch nicht mal mehr das gewesen, sondern you name it,
irgendein anderes Land, wäre der Fall vielleicht nochmal ganz anders geendet.
Aber ich fände sehr wichtig, dass du auch sagst, also zu diesem Ergebnis wäre
es nicht gekommen, wenn nicht die USA gesagt hätten, dass genau dieses Ergebnis
jetzt in ihrem Interesse ist, ne?
Und irgendwie, wahrscheinlich haben die sich überlegt, jetzt irgendwie unter
Trump oder einem komplett kreisen Biden,
hier noch dieses Verfahren führen zu müssen und dann am Ende das Problem zu
haben, dass Australien sich für seinen Staatsbürger dann doch einsetzen muss,
dass man dann halt sagt, komm ey, time served und fertig.
Der ist eh Matsche, wir haben unseren Punkt gemacht.
Jeder, der gesehen hat, wie der aus der Botschaft gezerrt wurde,
jeder, der dieses Bild sieht, jeder, der irgendwie daran denkt,
sich mit uns anzulegen, hat das in seine Netzhaut eingebrannt. Reicht.
Weil du die Wauholland Stiftung hervorhebst ich denke hier sollte man insbesondere
auch nochmal nennen es gab einen Menschen der einfach,
immer sich für Julian Assange eingesetzt hat der auch den größten Teil dieser,
Wauholland Stiftungs Arbeit gemacht hat und der,
in den letzten Monaten nur damit beschäftigt war wie viele viele andere Menschen
auch das ist Andi Müller-Magun.
Urgestein ein Mitglied des Chaos Computer Clubs, Vorstand der Waoholland Stiftung,
unterschiedliche Vorträge zu dem Thema gehalten und für den war das in den letzten
Jahren einfach das einzige Thema, womit er sich auseinander gesetzt hat.
Und ja, freue mich für, also ich freue mich, dass das jetzt irgendwie einen
Erfolg hatte, der, man muss es ja als Erfolg werden.
Ich hoffe, dass Julian Assange sich gut gesundheitlich erholen kann.
Er hat ja jetzt auch eine Frau und Kinder und,
hoffentlich noch irgendwie ein angenehmes,
Restleben hat und die ganze Scheiße verarbeitet. Weil das ist ihm ja bisher,
also wenn man sich anschaut, wie der aussah, das war ja wirklich einfach nur erschreckend.
Gut, können wir nochmal gucken, ob unsere anderen Dauerthemen dann noch halten.
Ja, nee, auch nicht Chatkontrolle. Chatkontrolle haben wir noch Hoffnung.
Dass es nochmal kommt. Dass es hier, da kommt noch was.
Wir hatten ja in der letzten Sendung dann, glaube ich,
noch live erwähnt, dass der belgische Ratsvorsitz das Thema jetzt nicht weitergetragen
hat an dieser Sitzung und dass es jetzt quasi aufgeschoben ist.
Und da haben wir dann jetzt auch nochmal die Forderung betont,
dass diese Verordnung jetzt mal auch einfach langsam weg muss.
Da gibt es einen gemeinsamen Brief, den der Chaos Computer Club auch unterzeichnet hat.
Die belgische EU-Ratspräsidentschaft ist nun das vierte Land,
dem es nicht gelang, eine Einigung über die umstrittene Verordnung zur Chat-Kontrolle zu erzielen.
So, jetzt müsste man irgendwie mal einfach auch anerkennen, wie fehlerhaft irregeleitet diese Idee ist.
Ja, und das kann man dann auch irgendwann einfach mal sagen,
okay, dieses Gesetz, was 2022 erstmals vorgeschlagen wurde, Ja, überleg mal.
Wird von jedem abgelehnt, wird von allen bekämpft, kriegst du keinen Kompromiss durch.
Die haben jetzt zwei Jahre intensiv intern darüber verhandelt.
Es ist nicht gelungen, einen Konsens darüber herzustellen. Und vielleicht sollte
man irgendwann auch mal sagen, vielleicht ist es wirklich einfach eine scheiß Idee gewesen.
Mal gemessen daran, dass alle sagen, es ist eine scheiß Idee und wir uns darüber
nicht einig werden, vielleicht könnten wir das mal als Messwert nehmen,
zu sagen, ey, weißt du was?
Vielleicht war das eine scheiß Idee. Vielleicht lassen wir das einfach.
Das wäre zu einfach.
Vielleicht lassen wir das einfach mal sein.
Und es wäre natürlich schön zu erkennen,
dass natürlich Kinderschutz trotzdem wichtig ist und dass man viel Geld und
Zeit auch hätte sparen und investieren können in tatsächlichen Kinderschutz.
Zum Beispiel Zusammenarbeit mit Kinderrechtsgruppen, Menschenrechtsgruppen,
Sicherheitsexperten und Technikern suchen, um neue technische und nicht technische
Lösungen zu entwickeln.
Sich auf die Umsetzung des Digital Service Act zu konzentrieren und sicherzustellen,
dass illegale Inhalte rasch und angemessen verschwinden,
dass man gegen die Inhalte vorgeht und gegen die tatsächlichen kriminellen Bannen,
Kapazitäten und Ressourcen in der nationalen Kinderschutzarbeit,
Hotlines und so weiter hochzieht und auf Prävention setzt.
Ja, Präventionsprogramme für potenzielle Täter, Wiederholungstäter,
Polizei- und Justizsysteme so umgestalten, dass sie diesem Phänomen auch irgendwie Rechnung tragen.
Und eben zu verhindern, dass der Missbrauch überhaupt stattfindet.
Das sind alles die Schwerpunkte, die hier zugunsten einer AI-Überwachungslösung
in den Hintergrund gekommen wären.
Und da wäre natürlich jetzt sehr gut, einfach tatsächlich mal zu überlegen,
wie kann man denn, was ist denn hier die Problemstellung, wie können wir der
denn vielleicht noch begegnen, außer mit Massenüberwachung. Soll ja Möglichkeiten geben.
Ja, gibt es dann noch andere.
Ja.
Okay.
Mal gucken.
So, dann war ein Kantorkel für den CCC im,
Innenausschuss des Deutschen Bundestags. Wir hatten da eine Einladung bekommen,
weil das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz reformiert wird.
Ein großes Thema. Viele sind dann viele Datenschutzleute und Gesellschaft für
Freiheitsrechte und irgendwelche Polizistinnen und Polizisten und vielen das alles so betrifft.
Wir sind da mit einer relativ kurzen, weil wir eben auch jetzt keine Juristen
sind, die da die Details dieses BDSG,
bewerten, wir sind mit einer relativ kurzen Liste an Forderungen da reingegangen
und haben gesagt, ach, wenn er gerade mal das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz reformiert,
könnte er einfach mal noch eben,
biometrische Fernidentifikationssysteme direkt mit verbieten.
Also biometrische Videoüberwachung im öffentlichen Raum verbieten, damit wir
Das jetzt nicht haben, denn diese Systeme werden ja bereits eingesetzt ohne
Rechtsgrundlage und da scheint uns,
scheint ja gerade wirklich ein großes Potenzial schwer wegen der Datenschutzrechtseinschränkungen,
Persönlichkeitsrechtseinschränkungen und großer umfangreicher Überwachung zu entstehen.
Da könnte man doch jetzt einfach mal gerade gegenwirken, bevor es zu spät ist,
versucht er bei anderen Sachen ja auch.
Dann, dass man halt mal auch mal gegen öffentliche Stellen Bußgelder und Zwangsmittel
geltend machen kann bei Datenschutzverstößen und dass natürlich das Recht auf
Auskunft geschützt bleiben sollte.
Das Recht auf Auskunft, da geht es ja darum, dass quasi gesagt wird,
naja, wenn es ein Geschäftsgeheimnis ist, musst du keine Auskunft erteilen.
Und das ist natürlich sehr lustig für Unternehmen, die vielleicht deine Daten
und ihren Umgang damit zu ihrem Geschäftsgeheimnis deklarieren.
Ja, und wenn jemand sagt, was habt ihr an Daten über mich und du sagst dann,
naja, sorry, das ist ein Geschäftsgeheimnis, dann ist ja relativ klar,
dass das jeder macht und wenn du sagst, naja, glaube ich nicht,
erklärt man dann, sagen die, ja, können wir dir nicht erklären,
das ist ein Geschäftsgeheimnis.
Also das geht natürlich so nicht.
Und dass das dazu führen würde, dass Unternehmen selbstverständlich Geschäftsgeheimnisse
auch so konstruieren würden, dass sie das Recht auf Auskunft dann eben nicht
ermöglichen, das ist ja völlig klar.
Ja, Anhörung wurde übertragen, gibt es wahrscheinlich auch eine Aufzeichnung,
kann man sich anschauen. Ja.
Diese biometrische Massenüberwachung ist glaube ich wirklich,
ich hatte das schon vor Jahren mal gesagt, das ist dann die allgegenwärtige
Überwachung, die wir aus dem Internet können im realen Leben und das sollte so nicht sein. Nein.
Übrigens auch eine Forderung der GFF, die auch Formulierungsvorschlag gemacht hat.
Und das finde ich sehr schön, weil es uns zumindest auch in den Medien dann
gelungen ist, diese Forderung prominent zu platzieren und auf diese Lücke bei
der BDSG-Reform hinzuweisen.
Und wir freuen uns natürlich, dass die dann jetzt von der Ampel geschlossen
wird, denn das können ja so nicht stehen lassen.
Ich habe gerade mal den Änderungsvorschlag im Bundestagszusammenfasser aufgemacht,
was ich immer sehr praktisch finde, um mal zu sehen, okay, wo ist das.
Findet sich also im Bundestag und im Bundesrat jeweils in der ersten Lesung,
beziehungsweise im ersten Durchgang, wie das beim Bundesrat heißt.
Und ja, bei der Videoüberwachung, das ist ja durchaus auch schon ein Thema,
steht hier nur, das ist jetzt hier die Zusammenfassung, also AI.
Bei der Videoüberwachung öffentlich zugänglicher Räume wird zukünftig nur noch
die Überwachung durch öffentliche Stellen geregelt.
Nicht öffentliche Stellen richten sich nach der Verordnung der EU 2016 slash 679.
Das ist das, was das Änderungsgesetz zu dem Thema derzeit vorsieht.
Okay, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob die AI da nicht so vielleicht ein bisschen
durcheinander gekommen ist. Das kann ich natürlich sagen.
Das ist das, was uns die allwissende Müllhalde hier vorwirft.
Ja, also unsere Forderung auf jeden Fall ist, es sollte genutzt werden,
um die unmissverständlich zu verbieten.
Ja, sollte, aber wird halt jetzt noch nicht.
So.
Damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung angekommen, nehme ich an.
Ja, aber damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung angekommen. Wir haben jetzt die
Situation, dass es gar nicht mehr so viele sind vor der LMP 500.
Das gibt uns einerseits die Möglichkeit,
dieses Fest gut vorzubereiten, uns auf die Sendungsgäste zu konzentrieren,
die wir euch da bieten werden.
Werden. Andererseits gibt es jetzt eine Durststrecke, Leute.
Aber das liegt auch daran, dass wir im Juli machen wir häufig,
ja, machen wir häufig ein bisschen Camping.
Die Nachrichtenlage dünnt ohnehin etwas aus. Das ist auch immer die Erfahrung.
Auch der Bundestag macht irgendwann mal Urlaub.
Das Sommerloch kommt.
Das Sommerloch muss dann durch andere Sachen gestopft werden.
Aber ist auch alles kein Problem.
Die Meta-Ebene sendet ja auch sonst noch weiter. Es gibt noch Freakshow,
es gibt noch UKW, es gibt Raumzeit.
Habe ich heute auch nochmal eine Sendung veröffentlicht. Also von daher, I've got you covered.
Ja.
Muss ja nicht immer so ernst sein auch.
Ist doch nicht ernst.
Was?
Meinst du unsere Themen?
Ja. Ist doch ernst.
Meinst du das ernst?
Oder ist das nicht dein Ernst?
Leute, viel Spaß in dieser Woche und in der nächsten und wir hören uns auch wieder bald irgendwie.
Sehr zeitnah. Genau.
Machen wir. Bis dann.
Ciao, ciao.